hey what's up my name's Samuel leaves
thank you so much for coming to this
video I'm going to share something in a
moment which is like my biggest secret
super golden nugget I want to talk to
you about about negotiation there's two
words that I use all the time when I'm
negotiating and I see people negotiate
in the trying to get deals they're
offering on properties and they're just
saying the wrong words they're just
doing the wrong language so I want to
tell you what I do and I'll negotiate
the property deal the first thing is
this never be the first person to make
the first figure so you're when you said
watch me doing live dealers you'll
always notice that I'll ask questions
such as if I was to buy the property
cash tomorrow what would be the lows
that you'd be able to accept and still
live with and then I'll shut up and I'll
wait to hit their figure and sometimes
if they're smart they'll say well what
figure were you thinking because they
know they know that the person to put
the first figure forward is the person
that usually loses if they make you give
the first figure next rule never offer
on a property unless you are embarrassed
so the first role is make them put the
figure at birth but if they don't the
second rule is never offer on a property
unless you're embarrassed if the figure
is you're no embarrassed then chances
are your offer is too high so put
forward an offer this look really low
third rule is be really specific in your
offer if the property's on for a hundred
thousand don't say I'll give you 80
because then what they'll say is they'll
say well let's meet you and not let's do
90 half my house so if it's over 100 do
say 80 say I can I can offer you eighty
one thousand two hundred fifty pounds
because when you put forward a really
specific or even though you might it
might look a bit stupid or a bit strange
it's what it's saying to them is it
saying that you've really thought long
and hard about your offer and for some
reason you've calculated it at that and
they're more likely to say yes or what
they might do is they might say how
about rounded up to eighty two and then
you have a deal rather than meet me in
the middle at 90 so always be specific
but the biggest thing that I do all the
time I use these two words I use these
two words probably every day whenever
I'm negotiating whenever I'm putting
forward offers and these two words are
fantastic if you are a deal package or a
deal sorcerer also if you're looking at
a problems it looks really good but you
don't want to make a formal formal offer
because you just want it up but at least
due diligence but you do want to put an
awful forwarding you do want to seal
something
so these are the two words that I always
use and the two words are if would what
are we by if what if I was to offer you
a tea mm would that be something you'd
be open to that's if what if I was do
would and then if let's say um going
yeah I could
you've not officially operated to you
just as if I was too operated to would
that be something that you'd be able to
accept if they say yes you can just say
alright awesome I'm really glad I just
need to go and crunch a couple numbers
and confirm for definite I'll get back
to you tomorrow
boom you just used the if would offer
the reason it's so awesome is because it
gives you that then gives you time it's
also really good because when you speak
it almost in hypothetical language you
know so it for stuff like cash tomorrow
what would be the lowest if would what
would be the lowest that you'd be able
to accept and still live with you
speaking hypothetically if I was to
offer you in cash what would you haven't
said did you gonna buy cash tomorrow you
just said it hypothetically then they'll
give you their lowest then you know what
their bottom line is you can then work
from there
so that's it just a few tips a few
strategies and win on negotiating
properties this is mentoring Monday so
you can mentor mother you get your
questions beloved I always answer them
in the first hour TV Tuesday usually
you've seen me out on the road you know
doing deals negotiating if you don't see
my financial freedom challenge or any of
the videos want out negotiating in real
life maybe in the States you've read
just check out and binge watch some with
this channel because there's some gold
dust on there and don't forget to come
to a property investors crash course
it's free
I don't even allow adverts on this
channel it's free because it's my
mission to see you guys successful as
long as one condition when you become
financially free please tell me so I can
get you on winners on a Wednesday if I
find out that you've become successful
because of my training and you've not
told me I will hunt you down
subscribe I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]